okay now last a little bit address
system here we want to talk about
preferences okay we've already mentioned
some of these up here in terms of like
you said kilometers without batting an
eyelid okay
so what are the clobbered codes of now I
just wanna make sure I start with the
right Road they're common kinds are
preferences the ones that we've already
mentioned they kind of fit in the middle
because they're not the biggest ones so
if you want to put in which red one I'm
going to go for the one two three fourth
row we're gonna put kilo in here okay
now the actual letter that we used for
kilo is just okay right and if you have
a gram what do you multiply that by to
get a kilogram a thousand right so over
here let's put that 1000 and we're just
writing that as an ordinary number but
of course we've lost scientific notation
right so how would write a thousand in
scientific notation okay good so being
that this is like times a thousand I'm
just gonna have times 10 to the power 3
because that's how many zeroes there are
okay and I guess you'd have some other
number like 5 or 2.3 or whatever
depending on what do kilos you've got
okay
remember these are these are preferences
what would come after kilo a B we don't
wear my feeling with the small ones so
what's smaller than that like you've got
a gram you've got a kid you've got say a
kilometer that goes up what's below
meter what's below meter there's a
there's a prefix we add it's centimeter
right said to you so you've got C and
then you add that on to and we get cm
okay so here instead of multiplying by a
thousand we're actually dividing by how
many centimeters in a meter a hundred
percent centuries that's where this
prefix is used right so what am I gonna
multiply by if it's dividing by a
hundred
I'll give you clue it's gonna have a
negative index yeah just 10 to the power
of negative 2 perfect okay cuz again
there's two zeros they're just going in
the other direction
okay uh after centimeters we get
millimeters right so that's an M that's
why we have mm but you've got ml you got
any other kind of theme how many meals
in a liter or how many millimeters in a
meter there are a thousand yes yeah
because you've got ten millimeters in a
centimeter and a hundred centimeters in
a meter yes so I've got three zeros all
together so I'm gonna multiply by 10 to
the power of 93 okay now from here the
rest of these are less cover so I'm
gonna fill them in but I think what's I
write the names you might know what they
are so you've got micro yeah yeah
because micro starts with the same
letter as milli they actually hijack the
Greek alphabet and they use this
character okay so that character there
it's like a U with a tail on the front
okay if you're curious it's actually the
Greek letter mu as it's the equivalent
Greek for M okay so that's why we use it
so you might you might see this on like
odd medications sometimes you'll see
that and that's micrograms
okay so micrograms are divided by a
million that's a really really small
number okay so being that how many zeros
are there six but you're getting smaller
so it's times ten to the negative six
okay one last one I alluded to before
but I didn't we didn't have any but
units you use n to abbreviate nano right
oh now you can see here you know how we
have like a thousand a million a billion
and each time you're adding three zeros
another three zeroes the next one is
going to be another three zeroes right
so this will be divided by one count the
zeros 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 going okay which
of course means that scientific notation
is 10 to the negative 9 okay right to
complete this out we've done we've gone
all the way to 8 there now let's get
that bigger again okay you've got mega
above key
right yeah okay yeah units but anyway
makeup to distinguish again because
things are getting bigger here but we're
using the same letter we use a capital M
okay
so we've out of like megabytes right so
it's a capital L than it is a bit we're
going to go this time we're going to go
with this multiplying by three more
zeros right so it's it's a million so
this is times ten to the power of six
okay
after megabytes I'm now sort of going
into data so we're gonna look at laid
out in more detail but yeah good so Giga
I suppose it's the closest now again
because we're getting bigger they
actually use a capital G even though
there's nothing else that's there so
capital G and it's times we've got how
many zeros one two three four five six
seven eight nine this is the next step
up okay so that also tells us the
scientific notation and now if you got a
computer with no really really really
big hard drive it will have terabytes of
storage now this is almost never comes
up in the context of like oh how many
tera liters of water did you teach you
that right but but they makes you the
perfect now because later when we have a
look at the focus study called
mathematics and communication we will
deal a detail with megabytes gigabytes
terabytes this is another three zeros
okay so one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve which
then tells you the accompanied
scientific notation okay okay now let's
try it close yourself now I'm gonna do
this once and then I'm gonna ask you
guys to do it for the others okay